[موسيقى]
تعتبر علاقه العشائر بالدوله العراقيه منذ
تاسيسها رسميا عام
1921 امرا جوهريا اذ كانت الطبيعه
العشائريه للمجتمع العراقي طاغيه في مطلع
القرن العشرين
فاكثر من 70% هم ابناء الريف وعشائرهم في
كثير من الاحيان كانت للعشائر العراقيه
ادوار مهمه ومواقف حاسمه في المحافظه على
السلم الاهليه وبسط الامن مثلما حدث بعد
الانفلات الامني الكبير عام 2003 بعد
احتلال العراق ودوري العشائر في تحرير
العراق من احتلال داعش عام 2014 لكن فيما
بعد اخذ دور العشائر منحا اخر يختلف عن
هذه الادوار في بعض الاحيان فكلما ضعفت
الدوله كل ما اكتسبت العشيره قوه وم
والعكس صحيح
احنا ما مثلا طالعين باجره ولا مثلا احنا
جايبين
القران قد ذكر القبائل
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم وجعلناكم شعوبا
وقبائل لتعارفوا الى اخر الايه
العشائر منذ القدم موجود انا اعتبر
العشيره كحكومه صغيره ولكن
كل فتره
تختلف عن اختها الاخرى
ويمكن توضيحه بعض المفاهيم العشائريه
كالقبيله وهي المصطلح الاكبر من العشيره
التي تشكل جزءا من كيان القبيله وقد تحتوي
القبيله الواحده على خمس عشائر اما
العشيره فهي مجموعه من الافخاذ التي تضم
عددا كبيرا من الناس يجمعهم انحدار واحد
ولقب واحد
فتشوف النسيج الاجتماعي للعراق هو العشائر
النسيج الجيد واللي تعهد الحياه المدنيه
تختلف عن العشائريه بهذا الاتجاه يعني صح
يعرف خال اخو امه بس ما يطور الهذا ما
يطور العلاقه هسه مثلا لا خالي لانه يجوز
واحد من بينهم اخذ عزاويه مخالفه هو ولد
عمه ولد عمه بس هو يصيح يخارج يقول خالي
الواحد خالي الكل وهكذا النسيج العراقي
الاجتماعي العشائر
والعشيره في المجتمع العراقي تكوين
اجتماعي سياسي مبني على انظمه وقوانين
خاصه تعرف في الفرات الاوسط والجنوب
بالاعراف العشائريه
وللعشائر قوانين خاصه تحكم العلاقه فيما
بينها بفضل النزاعات والخلافات حول ملكيه
الاراضي او عند حدوث مشكله ما
نحن ما عندنا قانون عشائري ولا قضاء عندنا
عرف عشائر وهذا العرف متوارث من خلال
اجزاءنا وابائنا توارثنا العرف العشاري
ولحد هذه اللحظه نحن متماسكين بالعرف
الاعشاب
يتدخل الجيش العراقي في كثير من النزاعات
العشائريه التي تحدث عاده في جنوب العراق
والتي يتم استخدام اسلحه مختلفه فيها
نحن كدوله دوله مؤسسات ودوله قانون ولدينا
ايضا العشائر العراقيه لهذا ما نرى ان
هناك تقاطع بين العشيره وبين القانون
بالعكس هم داعمين كثير يعني كل العشائر
عقده اجتماعات ندوات كان هناك توجيه
للمواطنين والافراد العشيره اللي ينتمي
الها المواطن انه هذا الموضوع حرام شرعا
قانونا لا يجوز وحقيقه دور العشيره او
القبائل العراقيه الاصيله كان لها دور
كبير ومشرف
بالحد بشكل كبير من استخدام
السلاح او اطلاق العيارات الناريه بدون
سبب
تقديرا بعد الرايه انا كرم وتقديري ولوجه
الله تعالى اللي راح وللمجتمع والغالبين
والقوات الامنيه هذا اللي وقعة
تعرف ما يسمى بالفصل والديه العشائريه وما
شاء الله ذلك هذه الاعراض والسنن
العشائريه موجوده كليتنا نتجه
عشائرنا في بعض الحالات لكن هذا لا يعني
انه انت
تخرج عن القناه
كانت القبائل العشائريه
بها سنينه وسنه ثابته السنين يراد بها
القانون العشائري والقانون العشري كان
ثابت
ولكن في وقتنا الحاضر
نادرا ما من
يتمسك
بالسنائن او السناين الاوليه
العشيره عباره عن حكومه صغيره
[موسيقى]
ولكن تختلف عن مفهوم الحكومه السياسيه
يؤمن مجلس القضاء الاعلى بالدور الذي
تلعبه العشائر العراقيه في المحافظه على
النسيج الاجتماعي في الحقيقه كلمه القضاء
الهمد والقانون خاص ولا يمكن ان تطلق على
اي تسويات تجري خارج اطار القانون او خارج
اطار المحاكم المختصه بموجب القوانين
النافذه في العراق فلا يوجد شيء اسمه
القضاء العشائري وانما هناك تسويات تتم
وتقوم بها العشائر العراقيه الكريمه في
الكثير من المنازعات التي تنشا بين
الافراد تنطلق من فكره اصلاح ذات البين
اللي ترسخت في المجتمع العراقي واللي اكد
عليها الدين الاسلامي الحنيف هذه التسويات
وهذه الترضيات تتم خارج نطاق المحاكم ولا
يمكن ان نطلق عليها تسميه القضاء العشائري
او القانون العشائري لا يوجد في العراق
قانون عشائري انما توجد اعراف
[موسيقى]
الستر والامن والامان بين قبيله
عطوان وقبيله الجبور نسلمها بالساده
يفتحها
ان شاء الله وقوفا
ابو الفضل العباس الفصل واقع
والمقاسير واقعه افتح الرايه سيد مخاصير
والفصل كله طالب نهدي سوره الفاتحه على
نيه الرضا بين جبور وخواننا
طياح الفصل
والمخاسير كلها ان شاء الله اكراما لكل
الموجودين مسبوقه بالصلاه على محمد وال
محمد
الثانيه وهي اتفاقات تبرم بين العشائر
لدفع الديات المترتبه على من يرتكب ذنبا
او ما يسمى عشائريا بالمسبب ويدفع المسبب
مبالغ من المال يتم الاتفاق عليها تسمى
الفصل وفي كثير من الاحيان تتعارض قيمه
الفصل مع الشريعه الاسلاميه ومن المصطلحات
العشائريه العطوه وهو عرف عشائري يعني
الوقت الذي يعطيه اهل المقتول الى اهل
القاتل لكي يجتمعون معهم ويحددون الديه
الفصل لكن في حاله مرور هذا الوقت بدون
حصول الفصل يحق لاهل المقتول قتل اي شخص
من اهل القاتل
لا يخفى على الجميع ان الاعراف العشائريه
مثل الفصل وتحديد الفصل وامتثال الفصل الى
فتوى للمرجعيه باخذ الديه الشرعيه واضافه
الى ذلك في زمن القرون القديمه هناك بعض
الظواهر كانت تعطى الفصليه من المراه
للعشيره الاخرى المتنازع معها لاهداف
تحقيق السلم المجتمعي بالصوره الحقيقيه
التي تكون مصاهره مع العشيره المتخالفه
معها حتى يكون انجاب اطفال ويكون من
العشيره المتخاصمه معها انجبوا اطفال من
خلال هذه المراه واصبحوا اقرب ما بينهم
وعدم تكرار الجريمه او القتل او الشجار
بينهم
[موسيقى]
تؤثر النزاعات والصراعات العشائريه
واستخدام السلاح على مختلف فئات المجتمع
العراقي سواء كانت لهم علاقه او لم تكن
الشاب المرحوم علي اكبر البياتي من منطقه
الشعب في بغداد راح ضحيه نزاع عشائري بين
عائلتين وتم قتله حيث كان فقط يمر بالمكان
الذي وقع فيه الحادث وهو واقف يعني
صدفه جيراننا يعني
علاوي شنو ما شنو شو اخبارك ما اخباري يا
معوتي الدنيا
فشغل عبالك
[موسيقى]
يعني شلون هو كل مريض يقعد يومهم هاي في
العشر دقائق
ذاك اليوم
اقعد استريح البيت
فهم طلع من طلع عشار العام لا والله صدفه
ابن عمه
قلت لك انا يعني ابن عمه صار علي
مكان الحادث اللي صار
صار اللي صار هذا اللي صار هذا يجي
يتحزم على
مرته زعلانه صارت مشاهده
حقيقه في بعض النزاعات العشائريه اللي
شاهد العراق في بعض مناطقه حوادث مؤلمه
باستشهاد مواطنين لا سبب لهم حتى في موضوع
الاعراس او
الفواتح او ما يسمى لدينا في الجنوب
بالعراضه كانوا يستخدم هذا السلاح بشكل
كبير باطلاق عيارات ناريه في الهواء هذه
الافعال التي يقوم بها البعض ادخلت الرعب
في نفوس الناس وروعت الناس الامنين
وتحول الموضوع الى شريعه غاب يعني كل من
لديه يذهب وياخذ حقه بالسلاح دون اللجوء
الى المحاكم لذلك كان لابد لمجلس القضاء
الاعلى ان يتحرك لمحاربه هذه الظاهره التي
بدات تتنامى في الفترات الاخيره فنص على
ان هذه الافعال تندرج ضمن الافعال
الارهابيه التي نص عليها قانون مكافحه
الارهاب في الماده الثانيه منه حينما تحدث
عن الافعال التي تعد من الافعال الارهابيه
ومن ضمن هذه الافعال التهديد والعنف الذي
يهدف الى القاء الرعب في نفوس الناس اذا
الدقه العشريه تندرج ضمن مفهوم قانون
مكافحه الارهاب المنصوص عليه في الماده
الثانيه ويعاقب عليها بالاعدام حسب نص
الماده الرابعه من القانون ذاته
عافيه يا ابطال
احنا بالعشيره عدنا قوانيننا الخاصه
لا لنا علاقه بدوله ولا احد يقدر يوقف
بوجهنا وهذا الشيء مو اليوم مو البارحه
فتحنا لقينا هنا وعمامنا
[تصفيق]
رغم كل القوانين والتشريعات التي منعته
وشددت على المحاسبه بموجبه لا تزال اليوم
كثير من النساء العراق يزوجن قصرا قادنا
بحثنا لمقابله سيده تعرضت لما يعرف
بالفصليه العشائريه الزواج القصري حيث
تطلب فيه العشيره المعتدى عليها من
العشيره المعتديه تزويجهم امراه من بينهم
تسمى الفصليه وبالفعل تم تزويج هذه السيده
واعطائها ثمنا لنزاع عشائري لا علاقه لها
به
ابن عمي يشتغل بالسوق
اتعارك هو ولد بصفه بمحل بصفه بيناتهم
واحد ضرب الثاني ابن عمي يضربها براسه
فصارت عشائر وقعده وفصول فهل الولد ذاكر
ولا فصليه وحتى مو زواج مثل العالم انه
يعني خدامه
اثنين نسوان وولد
اجوا يعني حتى وجههم ما بيه رحمه
اخذوني ورحت وياهم
فما اعرف شنو حتى كنت صغيره كان عمره 20
سنه ما اعرف شنو منفصليه وحتى اللي ما
اعرف شو اقول لك يعني عشت وياهم انه انا
خدامه هذا ابو فصليه ما عرفت شلون اتصرف
وياهم قبلت بالواقع على مود انه لا اخوه
اخواني تقتلون ولا ابوي يعني ينقتل
[موسيقى]
اللي لاحظناه بالمجتمع انه المراه
اللي تباع ثمن كفصليه لا تحترم في داخل
هذه العائله لا تقول لي انه حديث عام انه
تحترم وهي مظاهره وهي نوع من الاعاده
العلاقات لا ابدا تكون في وضع سيء يعني
تحرم من حقوقها اهم حق انه مثلا زياره
عائلته ما الها اي حق في هذا لا يؤخذ
بكلامها ابدا ينظر الى نظره نظره نظره
اخرى نظره مسيئه باعتبارها انها هي يعني
كانت ثمن لجاني يعني او انه من عائله قتلت
ابننا والى اخره هذه قضايا لا لا الواقع
يقول شيء ما نقول انه لو كانت هكذا يعني
ما شفنا هاي النزاعات المستمره والخلافات
المستمره بين العشائر ما شفناها تتوسع
بهذا الشكل اذا كانت هي ثمن بالعكس انا
اقول موقفنا كم منظمات مجتمع مدني حد
كثيرا حد من ظاهر من هذه الظاهره سواء
بتثقيف العشائر مو تدقيبه يعني
باعطائهم صوره عن الواقع المعاش وعن واقع
النساء والى اخره وفي وضع احنا نتحكم بنا
دستور اليوم اعتقد ان موضوع الفصليه وانه
هو تراجع كثيرا في الفترات الاخيره لكن مع
ذلك هذه الافعال هي من الافعال التي جرمها
القانون قانون الاحوال الشخصيه في الماده
التاسعه منه نص على ان من يكره غيره على
الزواج يعتبر قد ارتكب فعلا مخالفا
للقانون
ويعاقب بعقوبه مده الحبس لا تزيد عن ثلاث
سنوات اذا كان من اقارب الضحيه من الدرجه
الاولى واذا كان من الغيار فان العقوبه قد
تصل الى عقوبه السجن لمده عشر سنوات مثل
شنو يقول مثلا
المراه لازم اذا مثلا مع احترامات لك تخون
الزوج لازم نجي الهيابه
جزاك الله الف خير وانت ما مسويه في هالشي
[موسيقى]
قضيه قتل المراه بدوافع الشرف ما يسمى
بالنسبه للقضاء العشائري انا اللي اقوله
فقط اتساءل هو الانسان كائن المراه كائن
بشري اذا كانت طعن في شرفها ليش الرجل من
يتصرف تصرفات مهينه وايضا لا شرف ليش ما
يحاسب ايضا ليش المراه تحاسب انطيني ليش
ليش هذا التمييز في هذا الواقع ليش من
الايام اتكلم على الاسلام ايش قال قال
الاسلام يرجم المراه وكذا وكذا قلت له راح
بس اجاوبك اجابه واحده لو رجل تزوج بامراه
واربعين ساعه قايملها بالخدمه و24 عام يكد
على اطفالهم ليسوا باطفالهم بالاصل هاي
المراه ما تستحق تقتل
الاسلام جرم المراه اذا محصله ترجع هو
الله جرمها انا ما جرمها مره اللي تخون
الزوج تقتلها العشاء ممكن حتى قانون
العراقي اذا قضيه شرف ما اعتقد انه ينسجن
سته شهور ويطلع هو فقط يقتله يقتل نفس
بشريه حتى ان يرفع راسه والعقال يكون
مالته مرفوع على راسه وبهيبه هذا فقط
الجانب الاجتماعي اللي هم دائما يتصوروه
[موسيقى]
الشغله اللي سويتها وندمان عليها صراحه
اختي حبت واحد وهو اجى خطبها وراد يتزوجها
بس ابن عمي ناهي عليها وهي ما تريد ابن
عمي تعالي شردت ويا هذا اللي تحبه
فابوي وامامي والعشيره مقرره ولازم نقتلها
واني ظليت شهر ادور عليها الى ان لقيتها
وقتلتها ما كان عندي حل ثاني
لان اذا ما اقتلها اصير عار على العشيره
وهذا القرار ما ابي مجال للنقاش
شو تقرر العشيره اني لازم انفذ اولا موضوع
القتل هو موضوع مرفوض مرفوض دينيا يعني
حتى في الشريعه الاسلاميه هذه الجريمه من
الجرائم التي تشدد فيها
الشرع الاسلامي في موضوع الاثبات
ولم ياخذها على علاتها فهو مرفوض من ناحيه
الشرع ومرفوض من ناحيه القانون موضوع
القتل مهما كان الدافع ومهما كان الموضوع
حياه الانسان اثمن شيء في الوجود
[موسيقى]
يعني الطفل اولا راح يتربع على قضيه
الثائر يتربى على قضيه روح الانتقام يتربى
على قضيه انه الاعراف العشائريه هي اللي
تحكمه واللي هي يجب ان تخليه في مسيرته من
يكبر هذا غلط هذا غلط هذه يعني ثقافه
الناس توجهاتهم استقرار الناس مرهونه
بالخلافات بين هذه العشيره وهاي العشيره
وانا اعتقد مو مساله اصبحت عشائر وان ماتت
تستثمر من خلال نزاعات سياسيه تتوجه الى
هذا الجانب ولا حتى اذا ما جاء على علاوي
ورغم انه ترى الصوب
عمته
يعني هو جاي يقاتل مئه بالمئه يعني مو
متعني انه مثل عنده مثل حوار او عتب او
فشله
ان شاء الله ما يروح
ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]
العشيره هواي تظلم
اظلمتني
وبسبها انا دمرت حياتي
بسبب العشاء
وابوي لا اسكتي اخوي لا اسكتي
وحتى حتى اطفالي مو مثل العالم انه انا
عندي اطفال وافرح بيهم
واحبهم بسبب اهلي يعني حتى اطفال
انا حتى اطفالي مرات ما احنا عليهم
بسبب اهلي
عشيره متمسكين بعشيرتنا ازيد بالدوله
موثوقيتنا بالدوله مو مثل موثوقيتنا
بالعشيره
ثقافه مجتمعنا انه نطلع حقنا بايدينا
[موسيقى]
سؤال موجود
افتح الباب يوميا
[موسيقى]